thanks for coming and especially I
notice that there's a lot of law
students here tonight which is really
great i'm always really jazzed when the
law students come all the way up the
hill for us so thanks especially to the
law students for coming but to everybody
else too my name is Josh galperin and I
run the CL Center for Environmental Law
on policy and i'm going to introduce a
bill hohenstein tonight so bill is our
well actually I should say I'm probably
not the best person to introduce bill
because we've never met before today and
we'd only communicated by email and in
the midst of our email communications
there was a government shutdown that
some of you may have heard about so for
a few few days here we couldn't even
communicate by email 15 days yeah so so
I don't know everything there is to know
about bill but I'm really excited to
have him here because as many of you
guys realize obviously climate change is
a huge issue and food and agriculture
issues are really important across the
globe and especially on campus right now
it's something that people are really
talking about and and bill brings both
those two things together so I've been
telling people we're going to have bill
here and to talk about this and
everybody who I've told almost everybody
who I've told it said oh that's so great
we we know what bill does we know about
the work that his office does and we're
really excited to come see them and it
turns out that that's actually true so
I'm really really glad to hear that so
God just to say a little bit about a
bills background thing one that you
should know is that bill has a master's
in Environmental Management he is one of
the few people you were meet
particularly here who has an Emmy am
that isn't from Yale he's got one from
the Nicholas school this is should I add
something to that he's got one from Duke
so you've got only a couple places you
can get these and we happen to have
someone who didn't get one here the
other thing that you need to know this
is the important thing is that bill is a
director of USDA climate change program
office and in that capacity what he does
is run a team of people I presume as a
team whoo hoo look at the impacts that
climate change is having on on
agriculture in this country and
obviously that's a really broad range of
issues and a really broad range of
Agriculture if the USDA doesn't just
mean you know we and corn it means fruit
and it means forestry and it means a lot
of other things so it's a big job and
hopefully we'll get to hear more than a
little bit about what that entails
tonight so without further ado bill
thank you very much for joining us stuff
and does this work yep great band it's a
pleasure to be up it up to ya this is
actually my first trip to yell as and as
a Duke graduate that other master's
program in Forestry and environmental
studies and back when I went to Duke it
actually had a different name now it is
the Nicholas school of the environment
when I went there it was the school of
Forestry and environmental studies and
somewhere along the line the forestry
got lost from the the title of Duke so
it's really nice to be here at a
forestry school that still is proud of
being a forestry school as Josh
mentioned I'm the director of USDA's
climate change program office also
serving as the acting director right now
for a new office called the office of
environmental markets dealing with
market-based solutions to environmental
problems involving agriculture but I
want to talk primarily tonight about the
challenge that we face from climate
change and it's and it's going to be a
pretty basic talk but I'll leave plenty
of time at the end for questions it
looks like we're pretty good audience I
was thinking that we're going to be more
law students so some of this is going to
be a little bit of climate change 101
with implications for food security a
little bit about what we do at USDA to
position agriculture to deal with these
emerging challenges but again I'm going
to try to leave plenty of time for
questions where we can go into things
like biofuels or the farm bill or the
ongoing climate negotiations or whatever
you want to talk about is a broad range
of issues that we get involved with at
USDA so let me start at the beginning
just to get and to make sure everyone's
on the same page at as the director of
the climate change office at USDA I
spent a lot of time going out and
talking to farmers and farm groups and
far
organizations all across the country and
one of the first things we need to talk
about is is the climate changing and our
humans causing it so this question of
both detection and attribution and I try
to build the case for this because it's
really important that farmers understand
sort of what's happening with the
climate system what's driving it and
what the consequences are for them and
it and sometimes it's a difficult
conversation to have because you know
farmers can be an ornery bunch and they
have a variety of views with regard to
you know things like climate change and
so we start you know with the basics you
know the theory and in trying to address
a whole series of questions Siri do
greenhouse gases influence the climate
system if so how are the concentrations
of these gases changing and can the
changes in the concentrations we're
seeing be tied the human activity as a
consequence are we seeing climate change
our temperature is changing and are
these patterns consistent with what we
might expect given our understanding of
the climate system and then is it making
any difference on the ground and so I
try to go through these questions and
really build sort of the case that yes
in fact humans are having an impact on
the concentration of greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere greenhouse gases turn out
to influence the climate system and the
climate system is changing so we start
with the this is the high school science
101 graph which is you know we start
with the Sun and the earth you know
obviously we have a greenhouse effect
the gases in the atmosphere trap a
certain amount of radiation from the Sun
that gets not reflected but but we
radiated into the atmosphere in the form
of infrared radiation greenhouse gases
themselves turn out to absorb a portion
of that energy and radiate it back in
all directions and so some of the
radiation that gets absorbed by the
greenhouse gases ends up going back into
space but some of it gets radiated back
down to the Earth's surface which is
important because without a
greenhouse effect we'd have a an
atmosphere or climate system similar to
Mars rather than what we have here on
earth so there is a greenhouse effect
it's driven by the range of greenhouse
gases and it's sort of critical to
having a habitable planet now from a
human perspective what gases are most
important well the ones that are really
driving the changes are sort of three
greenhouse gases co2 nitrous oxide and
methane along with a set of synthetic
gases that are substitutes for co2 in
addition there are a number of gases
that we're putting into the atmosphere
that are countering some of this and in
fact some of these are pollutants things
like aerosols so2 and and and things
that relate to tropospheric ozone and
then finally there are natural forces as
well that that influence the climate
system periodically are these
concentrations increasing the atmosphere
and this is sort of the granddaddy of
all climate graphs this is the the graph
of co2 concentrations in the atmosphere
as measured at the top of the Mauna Loa
volcano in Hawaii now why they went to
Hawaii and went to the top of a volcano
to measure co2 in part because co2 is a
well mixed gas in the atmosphere but
it's not perfectly well mixed and in
fact if you take the co2 concentration
around a city like Baltimore or
Washington DC you're going to get a much
higher concentration than if you try to
select a spot that's out in the middle
of nowhere like in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean and so this is a very good
indicator of what we background levels
of co2 in the atmosphere and what you
notice about this slide is two things
one it's going up and its continuing to
go up so see what your concentrations
are increasing the second thing that is
really interesting from a land
perspective is that this is not a
straight line in fact it looks like a
sawtooth and that is this is the power
of terrestrial systems forests in
particular
could big shout out to all the forestry
majors out there the differences in co2
concentrations are driven by the this
season's in the northern hemisphere
there's much more land in the northern
hemisphere than the southern hemisphere
and as plants and trees grow and and
leaf out the absorb carbon and during
the fall and winter when the leaves fall
off the trees and they decompose and we
get we get more respiration than
photosynthesis we see increases in co2
concentrations amateurs so not only can
you see co2 concentrations increasing
you can see the effective terrestrial
systems on that on the co2 balance in
the atmosphere so we know greenhouse
gases have a radiative effect we know
that the co2 concentrations in the
atmosphere are increasing is it making
any difference well yeah we're seeing
clot the climate change as well and in
fact you know that change is actually
accelerating we're seeing greater rates
of warming over the last four decades
especially over the last decade in the
US and globally as well now temperature
turns out to be one of the most variable
elements of the climate system and it's
difficult to actually detect these
changes so we don't just look at that
surface temperature to see whether the
climate is changing we look at a number
of important variable sum or
observations some of which are much more
stable like glaciers sea ice ocean
temperatures you know these these
indicators are much more stable and
they're in fact if we look at the major
ones across the globe sea surface
temperature ocean heat content sea level
air temperatures snow cover all of these
indicators both within the US and
globally are heading in the direction
that we'd expect with human induced
climate change so this is what it looks
like if you go back over the last
thousand years
and in fact if you go past thousand
years you know think about the entire
period where humans have developed their
agricultural systems we've existed in
this very narrow band of climate system
globally we've had variations we've
certainly had warm periods we've had
cooling periods but we are now at a
point in the late part of the 20th
century in the beginning of the 21st
century where we're getting outside of
this range of what we've seen not just
going back a hundred years or 200 years
but going back over a thousand years and
these changes both in terms of extent
and pattern are entirely consistent with
the build-up of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere and the rate of buildup is
increasing and so while we're here this
is what we expect over the next century
with on the low end somewhere about a 2
degrees c which is really four degrees
fahrenheit of warming to upwards of four
to seven degrees of warming over the
next century centigrade so their Celsius
and yeah this is my Al Gore slide and
it's it's meant to alarm a little bit
it's it's quite alarming to me but we're
going to be well outside of historic
ranges by the middle of next century and
so you can see the extent of warming is
is pretty significant and in fact the
and there's also uncertainty what's
alarming to me somewhat is that we we
are tending to be on the high side so
both in terms of greenhouse gas
emissions were sort of on the high end
of what we'd expect in terms of the rate
of buildup of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere and then in terms of the
responsiveness of the climate system to
these buildups both of those are turning
out to be more on the high side than the
low side and so if anything you know the
this the projections that are showing
greater amounts of warming it seems to
be some of it through some of the early
evidence that that's the track that
we're on so what's evidence for
agriculture is that we are going to see
a significant amount of warming what's
also important to other factors that
don't jump out at you
from this graph is the pace of warming
the is going to accelerate and so right
now we're we're seeing about oh point
two degrees C of changing per decade by
the middle of next century we could be
seeing point six degrees of change per
decade and by the end point eight
degrees per decade and so for what that
means if you're a farmer while you may
be able to adapt to the changes you're
seeing right now your ability to adapt
in the future is going to be very much
compromised as there as as climate
change accelerates over the next century
I'm the third thing that doesn't jump
out at you immediately is that we do see
a lot of climate variability in the
record and what we expect with climate
change is not only warming an
accelerated pace of warming but
increases in climate variability like
what we saw in 2012 with the drought and
again when it when you think about
agriculture the increases in climate
variability may be as important as the
absolute rates of change and so what do
we mean by that well so this takes that
last graph and kind of puts it into a
term that I think most people understand
and this is the number of days that are
over a hundred degrees and granted
weapon connecticut so maybe not so much
an issue from here with anyone from
Texas Oklahoma Arizona so you're used to
having some experience with days that
are over a hundred degrees currently you
know we see maybe 10 to 15 days a year
where you get those kinds of
temperatures under the low emissions low
climate sensitivity scenario here's what
you see you see some regions of the
country with 50 to 75 days a year where
we hit over 100 degrees under the higher
emissions higher climate sensitivity
scenarios we can see significant chunks
of the country where you're seeing you
know 60 70 over a hundred days
of where we're hitting over a hundred
degrees in a given year and you know
that you know in some ways that's a you
know that can be a miserable future in a
in addition to these kinds of changes
you can think about the entire spectrum
of climate variability shifting over to
the left right for you this way and you
can also see in this projection that in
addition to having a shift in
temperatures the shape of the curve is
actually broadening so we're seeing
greater levels of climate variability as
well now a final way to look at this is
something that I you know I think makes
sense to people when you think about
records you know people tend to remember
the warmest day or the coldest day
within a season or within a month and
historically you know they've tended to
balance out if you look at the 50s and
60s up through the 70s we've averaged
about 121 generally if you look over
many decades and so we get about as many
hot records as cold records within the
within the u.s. within the climate
record now when you get out to 1990 we
were then seeing three point oh one
point three six times as many warm days
as warm records as cold records so for
every cold record we'd have 1.36 warm
records by 2000 it was a two to one
ratio so we had twice as many warm
records being broken as cold records and
over the last three years that's
accelerating as well we're in 2012 which
was the warmest year on record in the US
by a full degree we had four times as
many heat records being broken as cold
records
now what does this mean for food
security and agriculture I work for USDA
agriculture is a critical part of food
security but food securities broader
than just growing crops and in fact the
way FAO defines it it's there sort of
four elements of food security
availability which is what USDA
traditionally has been involved in the
production of crops the production of
food the quantity of food access can you
get to the food can the food get to you
are the transportation distribution
systems in place utilization is the food
that you expect there are the kinds of
crops that you that you rely on
available and can you use them are they
adequate for your diet and then finally
stability is that is it in is the food
available across seasons across years
all four of these elements of food
security are really critical and
failures in any one of them can cause
food instability and what we're finding
is all four elements of food security
are affected by climate change so we it
climate change can affect crop
production it can affect food
distribution systems we found that out
in the 2012 drought where it became
difficult to transport grains on the
barges along the Mississippi it can
change utilization where crops are going
to be changing where they're likely to
be grown and how they're likely to be
grown and then stability as well with
increases in climate variability we're
going to see increases in the extent and
and the frequency of things like severe
drought which will affect the stability
of the food system
so this next graph may take a moment to
load but it's and it may take more than
a moment to actually view but it's kind
of significant does anyone know what the
Palmer drought severity index is the pgs
I is anybody heard of this anybody all
from the law school or the PDS eyes it's
an index it's and it's a measure of of
really the amount of moisture in the
soil or a measure of both route and
wetness and with 0 being normal
conditions and so 0 in this graph looks
like this and you can see that we've
experienced across the globe in any
given year as we're kind of circling
through the last century periods of
drought and periods where things have
been wet around the world you and I want
you to focus specifically on some of the
major crop growing regions the Corn Belt
of the u.s. parts of Brazil parts of
Russia and an Australia and you can see
that over the last century we've
experienced drought we've experienced
periods of wetness but primarily that
range has been sort of in this minus 3 2
plus 3 we've had severe droughts that
have occurred in the minus 4 2-5 range
but they've been infrequent and as well
it periods of extreme wetness but these
these colors on the map do have
consequences for people and in fact if
you look at 2010 and this is a slightly
different color scheme this green is
really the blue that we saw in the last
graph this is Central Asia including
Russia and up through this is Pakistan
and what you can see in this graph is
the effects in 2010 of 10
hold on there we go one of the most
severe droughts and the Russian wheat
belt in 2010 we're twenty percent of the
crop was destroyed much of it was burned
where temperatures were over 12 degrees
Fahrenheit higher than normal and it
affected over twenty percent of their
production at the same time that was
happening in Pakistan we were seeing
some of the worst flooding in several
generations we're 1.6 million acres of
cropland was underwater 1600 people died
over 10,000 cattle were lost and you had
scenes like this and so when when we're
thinking about climate variability in
the effects of what we're seeing in
drought and extreme flooding conditions
it has a real implications for people
and there you know underneath this map
or you know people's lives so looking
into the future this is what we expect
and this is your I think one of the
first group to actually see this slide
this is work that we're doing for an
upcoming report on climate change and
food security that is going to be issued
in 2015 this is what we're doing with
the National Center for Atmospheric
Research and this is their first set of
projections have changes in climate
variability using the Palmer drought
severity index over the next century ok
one of the mid-range scenarios so this
is a four degrees warming you know in
the earlier slide I said the range is
probably from two to seven so it's not
the highest but it's not the lowest
either and what you can see over the
next century is we see greater periods
of drought and more severe droughts and
when we see periods of extreme wetness
we see higher extremes over larger areas
and we're also seeing across the globe
periods where these droughts tend to be
correlated so you'll see periods where
there's drought in the in the US and in
Russia and in Brazil all at the same
time so
while we're in the early stages of
analyzing this data what we're trying to
get from this is information on how much
climate change will affect the
probability of drought within a region
in any given year or any given period
and how likely we are to see
correlations and where we see drought
across the globe so again this is very
early work it's very interesting to see
it's a little alarming but it quite
important because again most of the work
that we've done to date where we've
looked at the impacts of climate change
on agriculture have focused on the
median effects 2 degrees warming 4
degrees warming and the economist joke
well I don't know if the great joke but
they talk about a well-behaved climate
change and what they can model using the
economic models is well behaved climate
change where it's predictable where we
know what the range of future
temperatures are going to be where we
don't see wild swings in changes in
extreme events and what we're seeing
with some of the latest regional
modeling is not only do we have to worry
about the climate change itself but we
also have to worry about increased
variability and increased drought
so is all lost well let me see if I can
keep going provide some hope farmers are
inherently adaptable they are an amazing
group and in fact again looking back at
the 2012 drought we can see how farmers
ferritin and in many ways how they were
resilient to the changes they're seeing
now what we're seeing today with their
response to climate change is what i
would call reactive adaptation they're
responding to what they're seeing on the
ground it's not proactive adaptation
where they're planning ahead and
incorporating information about what we
expect in the future was regard to
changes in the climate system but even
with that they're responding to what
they're seeing on the ground we're
seeing changes in where crops are being
grown we're seeing corn being grown in
North Dakota we're seeing changes in the
way crops are grown up through 2011 the
biggest problem that we had in the
Midwest was through the decade our
Springs were very wet we had very short
planting windows and in response farmers
purchased bigger equipment and were able
to get in and out of the fields in a
very short amount of time to take
advantage of the time when they could
actually work the fields in the spring
that wasn't the case in 2012 but what we
found in 2012 was that farmers that had
employed strong conservation practices
water conservation practices and
practices that enhanced the sale that
built soil carbon that built soil
organic matter we're able to withstand
much of what the 2012 drought through
with them not every farmer not in every
region but farmers that had strong
conservation practices did better the
farmer safety net turned out to be quite
important in 2012 the fact that we had
crop insurance for many farmers and able
them to survive the drought maybe not in
terms of producing crops but in terms of
being able to provide a crop in 2013 and
so and farmers used information
information that we were providing
through things like our drought monitor
our drought projections were quite
valuable to farmers and they utilize
that and making decisions about their
operations and then finally what we
found in 2012 compared to previous
droughts is that the the quality of our
crop the the genetic improvements that
we've made to corn and soybeans and the
commodity crops has made the plants
stronger and more more rigorous and
better able to withstand drought and so
if you compare national levels of
production last year to say that 1988
drought or the 1956 drought farmers
fared much better in fact as bad as 2012
was it was the seventh largest corn crop
on record and the eighth largest soybean
crop on record and so we were able to
continue to produce a crop we did have
pretty significant losses in both of
those commodities last year but it
wasn't as severe as you might expect and
part of that was due to the fact that
we've done a tremendous amount of work
to improve the quality of the corn and
soybean crop now that's not the same in
developing countries and while
developing country farmers are adaptil
adaptable as well their access to
technology their access to information
their access to resources to help them
invest in the kinds of practices that
are going to make them more resilient to
change all of that is less and as a
consequence when we see you know
increases in climate variability like we
saw in those projections they're going
to be much more severe for developing
countries and so while we don't
necessarily have the plan for how the
world is going to adapt to climate
change we do know what the tools are
going to be and we know what's going to
be important certainly continued
research and technology development
building stronger crops stronger drought
tolerance in our crops is going to be
important improve water management
technologies drip irrigation
conservation practices are going to be
extremely important building up organic
matter in the soil conserving the water
that we have
improving access by farmers to the
latest information so building from our
existing drought monitor to do a better
job of short-term drop forecasts
internationally we have a program called
fews net which is the famine early
warning system that operates both in
Africa and in Central America and that
those networks help provide farmers and
relief agencies with information about
what to expect with drought and what
what that will imply with regard to food
security actions in those regions
development and wealth is really
critical to this William you think about
climate change occurring over the next
century how economies evolve and you
know the more resources society has to
deal with things like climate change the
more adaptable they're going to be so
farmers in the US with more resources to
invest in technologies are going to be
better positioned than farmers in other
regions of the world where they might
not have that but as we see over the
next century we're already seeing
actually in places like brazil and
argentina and south africa where farming
systems are changing very rapidly and
looking much more similar to what we see
in the u.s. those systems are also going
to be more adaptable as well and then
finally building focusing not just on
food production but all the elements of
food security looking at food
distribution systems trying to reduce
waste still when we think about food
demand over the next century if we can
reduce waste if we can improve a
commodity utilization it's almost as if
we can improve production
so let me come back to the US and and
look at specifically how we expect
climate change to affect agricultural
systems standing in the Northeast we do
expect to see higher temperatures but in
some cases that's going to mean longer
growing season farmers in the Northeast
we expect to have maybe a wider variety
of crops that are going to be able to be
grown although some crops that currently
rely on chilling like the apple crop
could be adversely affected we will
exceed changes in extreme events
primarily of concern for the Northeast
is extreme precipitation events and
coastal flooding in the Midwest we also
expect to see more rainfall falling and
extreme events versus what we've seen
historically here the increases in heat
events where we get days and especially
nighttime temperatures of that are that
are high are going to affect the quality
and the and production of our crops
we've already seen growing seasons
lengthened by over two weeks since 1950
but at the same time we've seen wetter
Springs and fewer fewer workable field
days and we expect that to continue for
most years with maybe some increases in
these severe droughts that we've seen as
well and the southeast drought is
certainly going to be an issue water
availability is going to be an issue
here you're going to see temperature
drive many of the effects that we see in
agricultural systems and not in a good
way and an expansion of of pests and
diseases that we don't typically see in
the US and the Northern Plains water is
certainly going to be a great concern
but like the Midwest you're going to see
longer growing season and some
additional opportunities to grow a wider
variety of crops but that's going to be
dependent on whether water is available
the southern plains and Southwest
together are the regions of the country
that are going to be most adversely
affected by climate change and they get
the sort of this double whammy of
of higher temperatures where they don't
really need higher temperatures with
reduced water availability more drought
less precipitation and importantly for
both of these regions a reduction in
snowpack the winter snowpack and the
southwest in particular is really
critical to agriculture because it's
where water stored for the season and
what we see with climate changes more
precipitation falling as rain and let us
know and so it runs off immediately and
it's not and isn't stored and that's
going to have implications for
agriculture we will also see that in the
Pacific Northwest where they have some
of the same issues with the northeast of
specialty crops being adversely affected
so it's USDA doing about this well one
of the things that we announced or our
Secretary just announced in June was we
are going to take a regional approach to
how we support farmers and how we
integrate climate change into virtually
all of our programs and activities and
services and we're going to do that
through and the establishment of seven
regional climate change hubs one for
each of the regions that that you just
saw the mission is going to be to
position agriculture for the challenges
that we expect to face over the next
century initially we think these hubs
will have three main functions one is
analytic each hub is going to be asked
to do a climate risk assessment a risk
and vulnerability assessment and also
serve as the repository within that
region for climate forecasts and
projections as significant
responsibilities these hubs will be to
evaluate and assess new technologies and
practices that can help farmers become
more resilient to climate change and to
provide that sort of technical support
for our programs our outreach and
extension programs or conservation
programs and then finally education and
outreach we were very interested in
working with extension working with the
universities we think about the
land-grant universities but the private
universities
as well that have an important role to
play and working directly with
stakeholders and building resilience to
the challenges that we're going to be
facing and then providing information
directly to the public as well
internationally USDA has important
responsibilities and we're working with
our partners both in nongovernmental
organizations groups like the World Bank
the FAO the OECD and other governments
were very excited about launching a new
initiative on what we're calling climate
smart agriculture which is an effort
that we're doing jointly with the
governments of the Netherlands and South
Africa this program will have three
goals enhancing sustainable production
adapting to climate change in mitigating
greenhouse gas emissions all
simultaneously through the same program
we work on a variety of programs with
the World Bank to address tropical
deforestation and we're hoping to take
some of what we're learning through our
domestic climate hubs and apply that
internationally as well and so I realize
I covered a lot of ground there's a lot
of things that I didn't talk about and I
mentioned this right at the beginning of
our talk we could talk about things like
the farm bill or biofuels or the ongoing
maybe never ending international climate
negotiations why don't I stop here I
think we've got maybe 20 minutes or so
for questions you can throw out topics
and I can address them
see you so that question raise your
hands and
hi thank you for coming um I was to be
I'm at the beginning you mentioned the
market solutions program that you were
starting maybe we should talk about you
know what you're doing and what examples
in norther sure this office of
environmental markets and and this
program this office was set up to help
establish emerging environmental markets
now what's an environmental market it's
basically where there's demand for an
environmental good or service something
like carbon sequestration or
improvements in water quality reductions
in nitrogen phosphorous from waterways
wetland habitat wildlife habitat
endangered species habitat so this
office basically has three tasks one is
to define the metrics for what defines
an environmental good or service and so
how you quantify tons of carbon or tons
of methane reduced or pounds of nitrogen
avoided from a stream it has a role in
working with the regulatory agencies
these environmental markets don't
operate in a vacuum or sometimes they
operate voluntarily but more often they
they work in concert with environmental
regulations and so there's a there's a
regulated entity whether it be a water
treatment plant or a utility that is
looking for environmental improvements
and can partner with farmers and
producing those environmental
improvements and so we work with the
regulatory agencies to incorporate this
market-based flexibility into their
programs and then finally we help with
established guidelines for verification
systems so so that if this environmental
good or services is produced folks have
confidence that it's real and that it's
um it's going to continue it's a small
office it's been around for now three
years in the office of the chief
economist
we focused a lot of our efforts right
now on the first the first task
developing water quality standards and
developing greenhouse gas standards for
agriculture
hi thank you very much for your talk you
mentioned the shifts in corn production
in the northern clean and that made me
wonder about a couple of things related
to that topic first how how you see the
shifts in crops proceeding with climate
change particularly in the northern
plains um well there and how do you
think that will impact trade so I'm
thinking of more corn being produced in
the northern plains means last week
being produced how does that impact our
national food supply how does it impact
our trade with Canada or other northern
countries and then same question for our
trade with southern American countries
that might be producing corn that that's
a good question i'd be competing with
their markets yeah nationally corn
production has expanded pretty
dramatically in the last five years
we've gone from about 70 million acres
of corn production to over 90 million
acres of corn production and some of
that is an expansion of corn northwood
northward and it's been driven by a
variety of factors climate is one so
longer growing season certainly has
played a role the availability of short
season corn corn that matures and say 75
days versus 90 days that's that's played
a role and then prices also played a
world the fact that we've had very
strong markets for corn in part driven
by ethanol that's also played a role in
the expansion of corn so it's been sort
of a you know it's hard to pin down
exactly what any of the effect of any
one of those single factors is but price
certainly is playing a role and and
climate is playing role and changes in
technology are also playing a role that
is having an effect on on we tweet is a
very flexible cropping can be grown in
many regions of the world and so while
there were it did affect wheat prices
what you've seen is that the markets
have responded so as as US production of
weed
shifted there are places where where
that can be picked up and the longer
term when we think about climate change
driving commodity production northward
most of the long term modeling shows
that but there are limits to that as
well because some of the region's that
come into play from agricultural
production in parts of Canada look ideal
from a climate perspective for growing
commodities but the soils really aren't
there so you know that from a climate
perspective you know we could keep
marching north but if you don't have the
soil to grow the crops lake in many of
the region's in northern Canada you know
they're going to be limits just
wondering what's what's happening with
crop insurance and you see any
particular trade a trends right now
going on with a changing climate yeah
again 2012 a good example of that we've
certainly seen a an expansion of the
crop insurance program to cover more
crops and more farmers over the last
decade and that trend is expected to
continue the crop insurance program is
responsive to climate change as we see
losses and as we see claims within the
crop insurance program they way the more
recent data more heavily in terms of how
they set premiums and so if we see a
series of losses within a County for a
certain crop it's going to make those
premiums more expensive and farmers are
going to react to that and so we get a
lot of questions about you know does the
crop insurance program can create a
buffer where farmers won't react to the
changes we're seeing but there are
elements that are built into the program
that make it responsive to to climate
change
I assume excuse me I think it's really
great that you're setting up hubs for
information information and training
programs to kind of create more
resilience in management practices and
and farmers I was wondering are there
any efforts behind the scenes to modify
the Agricultural Economics the subsidies
different types of market tweaks to try
and introduce new crops that might have
we have yeah certainly expanding market
opportunities as a priority for the
secretary it's one of the things he
talked about all the time isn't one of
his interest is in biofuels and
bioenergy is that it will expand markets
and it will expand opportunities to
farmers to grow new crops within these
regions so you know what we see with
climate change is that dry season crops
things that you could grow for bioenergy
like switchgrass or sorghum you know
could be viable for farmers you know
with regard to the discussions within
the farm bill and how there whether
they're counting for climate change or
not I don't see a lot of that happening
agriculture is a very adaptable system
and so while we're seeing some shifts
already to the changes we're seeing much
of our effort with regard to climate
changes to position agriculture 20 30 40
years out so we're prepared for these
longer-term challenges where we see
where the rates of warming and change
hi I'm curious about efforts related to
shifting fixed infrastructure around
agriculture because if you're looking at
like a lot of the dairy in the Northeast
or even like the fruit producers those
are kind of longer term investments with
that are difficult to move yep and here
there there aren't easy answers and the
the need for improved information and
the importance of planning ahead or
really critical so you know for any sort
of capital investment that a farmer is
going to make whether it be in a new
orchard or a new barn they need to be
thinking about what the future climate
system is going to look like we see a
lot more advanced planning right now in
the forest sector we're certainly forest
products companies but also state
foresters and folks within the National
Forest System are integrating climate
change into planning decisions and in
part that's because the decisions that
are making on the ground today are still
going to be in many cases in place 30 40
50 60 years from now we're for farmers
many of their operational decisions last
a season or at most a few seasons and
while farms can be highly adaptable to
climate change there are going to be
certain decisions they make about
capital investments whether it be around
water or barns or perennial crops where
they really need to be thinking about
what the future is going to look like
thank you for your lecture um I imagine
this might be a bit hard to give to
audiences such as farmers and I'm just
curious what their reaction is and if
you see any sort of change happening
amongst that group of people yeah yeah
my sense is farmers actually they
reflect the population broadly you know
if I as when I give presentations to
farmers I get farmers that stand up
course the climate is changing just look
at our farm look at what my father
farmed look at the way my grandfather
formed we're certainly seeing changes
and then you'll get other farmers that
say ah you know these are just cycles
we've had cycles in the past we're gonna
have cycles in the future and so in many
ways the perceptions that farmers have
about climate change are shaped by what
they hear in the public debate and they
reflect sort of the the variety of views
that are out there in the public what I
try to get them to in terms of a point
is that it's a risk you know there's a
consensus within the scientific
community that this is happening and
well they can believe it or not believe
it they should at least way it as an
important risk that they should be
managing for and and farms are very good
at managing risks they deal with you
know economic risks they deal with
physical risks they deal with whether
risks all the time and so talking about
to about climate change to farmers in
terms of risk management is pretty
effective I'm the other thing that we
find that's effective is that when we
talk about what USD is actually doing
about climate change investing in
drought tolerant seed or improve water
management systems or improving our
drought forecasts and projections
there's pre strong consensus within the
farm community that these are good
things and these are the kinds of things
that they want to see USDA investing in
hey what is and maybe made do it again
Oh both
ya know globally agriculture is an
important contributor to greenhouse gas
emissions about 13% of emissions
thirteen to fifteen percent come
directly from agricultural operations
globally Agriculture's also contributes
to deforestation which is about another
fifteen percent of emissions and so you
think about the land sector globally
about thirty percent of the problem
comes from the land sector in one form
or another and so it's really important
to tackle those sources of emissions and
take advantage of opportunities to
sequester carbon I don't think I haven't
seen studies directly of the role that
transportation of commodities plays in
emissions I mean certainly the large
sources are animal production livestock
production the use of fertilizers and
and on-farm energy use and say we have
programs pretty much across the board to
improve efficiencies in all of those
areas one of the things that we find is
that one of the best ways to reduce
emissions is to improve efficiency and
so if you can increase production you
can reduce emissions per unit of output
and that's really important especially
in the livestock sector where some of
the best opportunities to reduce
emissions are actually to enhance
production
a lot of people have talked about the
carbon benefits and climate benefits of
improved agricultural policies and so
I'm curious what progress has been made
towards incorporating the u.s. egg
sector into carbon markets that's been
you know it's something I've worked on
extensively I mean there certainly are
cost effective mitigation opportunities
in agriculture and so if you just look
at it in terms of an efficiency
standpoint there are reductions that you
can get by enhancing soil carbon
planting trees in certain areas reducing
nitrous oxide emissions that are very
competitive with other options for
reducing emissions from the energy
sector the challenge is how do you
actually connect those and create
markets and we have not at a national
level come to any sort of consensus on
that there were you know there were it's
happened in fits and starts you know
initially the Kyoto Protocol was a
market-based approach to deal with with
climate change the latest attempt was
through you know the legislation that
was debated in 2010 with Waxman Markey
and McCain Lieberman and he though you
know those pieces of legislation had had
marquette approaches and offset
approaches for agriculture where
agricultural markets could have
developed we're continuing within USDA
to lay the groundwork for what could
support a market program we're
developing sort of the tech the
technical standards for how you quantify
units of reduction from agricultural
technologies and so you know within a
state or within a county if you plant
trees at a certain density we can
quantify how much carbon you can expect
to sequester or if you reduce nitrous
oxide nitrogen and applications we can
quantify how much nitrous oxide you are
expected to save that's just a piece of
it you sort of need the legislative or
the market underpinning
that's being led right now at the state
level with you know the state of
California pushing a market approach
within the Northeast there's the Reggie
system and you know well I'm not an
expert on this the Clean Air Act which
is the vehicle right now that's the
primary vehicle for addressing
greenhouse gases at a federal level
there may be some opportunities to
incorporate market approaches into it
but it's going to be complex and it's
going to take time to work through right
now we're focused on our programs trying
to incorporate these technologies and
practices that have benefits into our
conservation programs and so when we
work with farmers through programs like
equip or the Conservation Reserve
Program or the conservation security
program we're making these greenhouse
gas mitigation technologies priorities
I actually wanted to return some of your
comments on measuring different kinds of
environmental impact and measuring
different kinds of environmental benefit
are there any categories that you feel
right now are I guess particularly
harmonious the stakeholders agree that
this is how the impact should be
measured we know how to measure it and
the measurement is accurate in any
categories which you think are
completely in discord basically no one
can agree how to measure it we can't
measure it or we don't have the accuracy
well I think the the mission reduction
technologies tend there there's more
agreement on so reducing nitrous oxide
reducing methane emissions and then
carbon sequestration lens ended several
levels of complexity because you're
actually storing the carbon in the soil
or in trees and you have to deal with
the fact that it's going to stay stored
and in some cases you're changing land
use as well and so you're altering
production and so you have all of these
sort of terms that get widely thrown
around in in the carbon market space of
additionality and leakage and permanence
and uncertainty and and they all relate
to various concerns that that people
have that the reductions that you
achieve for from offsets are real in my
view the emission reduction
opportunities are more easy to quantify
in many cases and have fewer issues with
regard to permanence and leakage I think
we are doing a pretty good job of
quantifying water quality benefits and
in fact the tools that USDA is developed
for assessing water quality improvements
are already being used in markets and
the Chesapeake Bay in the Pacific
Northwest and are going to be it adopted
in regions like the Ohio River Basin as
well and so there's you know the cases
where we're actually creating not just
pilots but real markets using these
technologies
techniques
ok
organic content to the soil
yeah no that's a in fact NRCS are for
Natural Resources Conservation Service
is going to be launching a national soil
health initiative because it not only
are there climate adaptation benefits
from enhancing soil health there are
mitigation benefits for expanding soil
organic matter in soil carbon the
nutrient benefits their production
productivity benefits there are
reductions in and run off and so the
practices that can enhance soil carbon
and soil organic matter use of cover
crops use of conservation tillage
organic amendments and these are really
critical practices to help farmers be
more resilient to climate change and
also can help effectively reduce
emissions by storing carbon
that's a good place to end it you know
up Dicer